Johnny Yong Bosch we here at collector
mania how you enjoying your day so far I
mean great yeah yeah obviously looking
front of you you've done so much voice
working like Naruto and bleach full
metal alchemist all this stuff how do
you find doing voice work and how is it
different to actual acting I guess the
difference is I can show up in my PJs
you know and obviously if you're on
camera you you just you're what you are
you know unless you're in a giant
costume but um yeah I mean it's it's
acting but it's a little it's just
different you know it's not something
you do then you turn up in your PJs
sometimes I do well speaking of acting
in your PJs the Power Rangers costumes
could be kind of considered pajama like
so you were going involved in Power
Rangers why do you think it's been so
successful that it's basically still
going today and it's such a huge thing
for children well I mean back then it
was really huge and it was there was
nothing like it really you know for kids
like an action-packed that ever it's
colorful you know and giant robots and
toys and Saban had a lot of money you
know so he could really push it and yeah
it just got big and especially at that
time and that should continue you know
as far as like the show and now that
stuff's just retro you know people
remember it back like I don't know like
I would remember Saved by the Bell or
something you know so it's kind of cool
they've announced it rebooting Power
Rangers and watching the needs to
different to make it kind of timely
today or do you not think they do need
to change it at all I mean it depends on
what what they're wanting to do I mean
are they going to make it for kids you
know are they going to make it for the
audience that grew up with it you know
are they going to use Mighty Morphin
like in my mind I would think they would
use Mighty Morphin because that was the
first one and they would probably do it
for kids it wouldn't wouldn't be a bad
idea to throw some of the like us in
there as cameos obviously cuz I don't
look like high school kids anymore but
uh you know just to Pete just to please
the fan set knew the show you know so
that there'd be that you know connection
and everybody be happy but I really
don't know what they're gonna do with it
Lionsgate you're actually the company
involved in doing it they've worked on
divergent and Twilight things like that
so they they've kind of hinted they
might be targeting the kind of young
adult audience do you think it worked
for that sort of audience I think so
yeah I mean if Power Rangers has always
been a kids show you know but people
still watch it from all ages you know
and especially ones when you grew up on
it some of those people still watch it I
think I can't imagine Saban would do
anything that's not that he can't sell
toys for you know because that's I mean
he's got to make money off of it and I
can't imagine if he were to do Power
Rangers that there would be that adults
would buy the toys unless there was a
reason you know there's good enough
reason just thinking and about the
casting you said you'd love to return as
a cameo how about a bigger role could
you pay a father of one of the high
school of these days I would love to be
a floating head I would like to be
soared on just the things if you view a
Rangers observe the viewing that Adams
dead but as floating heads there but
just thinking about dream casting I've
heard names rumored people like Anton
Yelchin Garrett Hedlund is there anyone
you'd like to see in a Power Rangers
movie particularly possibly playing a
black Ranger no no a
is it I'd like to see an Asian kid in
there but uh I don't know I haven't
really thought about it too much just
not Justin Bieber that no to producers
and not to cars custom Eva
thanks very much I'll let you gum your
day and thank you so much speaking to us